any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
hi everyone this is a little bit of a
departure from what you might have
become used to
here on my podcast into the impossible
podcast
i welcome you or i welcome you back to
a discussion which i hope you will find
quite
illuminating and that involves uh
perhaps the greatest most influential
book
in my life and that is
galileo's dialogue concerning the two
chief world systems this book more than
almost any other had a dramatic
influence on my life and my career
my world view and my perception of the
craft that i practice as a scientist
and even influenced me to be a better
writer a better communicator and
to do my best to really contribute to
the great
canon of scientific literature
i re-read this book recently
and many of you may have discovered that
from watching the interview i did with
michael knowles on the prager
university book club and i'm thinking of
calling this segment
of the into the impossible podcast book
scope or
book collider or great books
because uh there are several books that
were very formative upon me
in my youth and continued to influence
me to this day
so much so that the writing of galileo
in particular has
dramatically influenced my career
as i say but also in my writing as i
recount
in a chapter three of my book losing the
nobel prize
a story of cosmology ambition and the
perils
of science's highest honor i'm going to
read to you a passage where
i first introduced galileo and then i'm
going to take you through
the three uh really most important
aspects of galileo's dialogue book
highlighting from the wonderful
excellent translation really
unparalleled translation
by stillman drake who is a professor
also at the university of california
this one at the university of california
berkeley
and i'll read over the next several
days no hours i'll read different
selections of his
and kind of give you some my thoughts as
to why i think they warrant such
uh such merit and such note and how i
think you'll benefit
but even if you're not a scientist
you'll learn a tremendous amount
galileo was a virtuoso he was a poet he
was a true renaissance man
he had a deep and abiding faith both in
mathematics
and in religion in god and i think
his story is a uniquely human one that
resonates throughout the ages as have
been depicted in many different
uh forum for uh such as uh bertel
breck's play uh the life of galileo i
think it's called
innumerable books including one just in
2020 by my friend professor
mario olivio uh wrote a book called
galileo and the science deniers
in which case he makes the case rather
that the world in which we inhabit is
not
so different between that and nowadays
in galileo and what he faced
hundreds of years ago 400 years ago the
dialogue
is coming up on its 400th anniversary
and that'll be in uh in 2032 so a mere
12 more years to go
uh and it's as readable as ever so i'll
read passages from that
i'll take i'll give you three major
takeaways that i get on galileo the
scientist
galileo the philosopher galileo
of the human being and the forces that
subjected him in
all those different uh venues and how he
is a lesson and a model for uh
for many of us scientists but also a
cautionary tale as to what we should
avoid to do and i don't just mean the
so-called imprisonment the trial the
torture of galileo
we'll debunk that myth later on but uh i
want to
kind of highlight why galileo's plight
was in part due to his human nature and
his desire
as a scientist that could not be
separated
from the political forces that were at
work at his time and in his age and
some of his personality quirks that
come to light only much much later but i
want to do it as a scientist as an
astrophysicist
because i think i have a special kinship
with fellow astrophysicists and i hope
you'll indulge me
uh if you are interested in galileo as i
am
and noting that there are no great
audiobooks
uh for the dialogue and even any of
really galileo's books they're known
modern audiobooks i would love to be
connected with anyone out there
who would like to work with me on making
a proper translation
not a translation a proper recording of
this audio book this version by
galileo by galileo but by stephen j
gould's series that was
based on the translation by stillman
drake
which has as a forward i'll read parts
of it from none other than albert
einstein who is deeply influenced
by galileo few people know galileo was
really the first to think about
relativity relative motion
of observer and source and galileo
influenced einstein tremendously so i
don't know how long this will take it
could be split up over many episodes
again i want to encourage people if
you're interested to reach out to me
here on youtube or on itunes twitter
at dr brian keating dr brian keating and
let me know if you're interested in
maybe partnering together
to bring galileo's voice
to to the ears of a modern generation
seeing as those of you who are listening
obviously enjoy listening
to long-form podcasts and of course this
book is quite long it's 539 pages
uh galileo's own text and then there's
the introduction
by albert einstein that's worthy of
trends of transmission
of recording too if uh if i can find a
good partner
to record an audio book again reach out
to me please
but for now let's start with the
influence in my book losing the nobel
prize when we first meet galileo
and it's chapter three i call it a brief
history of time
machines and that's because i view
telescopes as time machines
so this actually goes back before the
the dialogue
back to galileo's first major book
that led to international celebrity and
that was cedirius nuncius
or the starry messenger in which he
introduced
the discoveries that he had made in the
new theories that he was beginning to
put forth in favor of copernicanism in
favor of heliocentrism
based on the observations with a
telescope that he perfected even though
he didn't invent it there's some
lore that he invented it he did not i'll
talk about that
at some point and maybe we'll do another
uh
discussion like this on sidirius nuncius
because that also had a tremendous
influence on me
but that's almost more of a of a lab
notebook or observat observation log
what's unique about that book is that it
has galileo's own
hand drawings and paintings and washes
of the moon surface the moons of jupiter
their positions etc and that's an
incredibly unique and rare
and expensive book the dialogue came
later and
it's much more lengthy and works out the
philosophy behind
galileo's support of the copernican
system
as it stood in opposition to the
conventional ptolemaic or aristotelian
peripatetic as he calls in in this book
worldview
and and i will explain what the meaning
of that was and why it's so
important in my mind that we that we
explore it because it is as i said in my
interview
with michael knowles and prager
university it is the first maybe the
best
work of science writing as literature
so it's written with a beauty a prose a
poetry and verse
and it's making these incredibly complex
arguments uh
that some of which are not correct and
not really worthy of too much study
other than for the fact that
the writing is so delightful and
it's really a work of art in terms of
literature
as i have said and as none other than
stephen j gould said
in his introduction but let me turn back
to brief history of time machines
playing on stephen hawking's
uh brief history of time i say the
journey we're about to embark on will
take us back to the very beginning of
the universe
but reading this story requires a very
special pair of glasses
a set of lenses first used by none other
than galileo galilei
on a balmy night in june in 1609
that evening galileo did something no
never done before he looked up
through a tube that was destined to
become a biblical bludgeon
he had come to the tube in a rather
nefarious way committing academia's
cardinal sin plagiarism his friend
paolo sarpy had recently told him about
a new device invented by a dutch
spectacle maker
that could make distant objects appear
closer remarkable
remarkably even though he had not seen
the dutchman's device galileo not only
reproduced it
but built several more with vastly
improved performance
soon his perspiculum quote perspective
tube or spy glass
would become the shortest lever ever to
move the earth
it was a simple invention really two
glass lenses within a flimsy lead too
each lead each lens had one flat side
one of the lenses was bowed out on one
face
squashed like a lentil indeed the
diminutive legumes latin name is the
origin of the english word lens
lentil means lens our lens means
lentil shaped the other lens reverse
face was concave bowed in
each lens was about five centimeters in
diameter the one closer to the object
under study
the objective was at arm's length from
the eyepiece which unsurprisingly is
where you put your eye
the combination of those lenses placed
the perfect distance apart
magnifies distant objects giving you a
perspective
in the span of one remarkable week in
june galileo perfected the device
soon afterward he increased its
magnification to 30 power
up from about what sarpy had explained
was about three power
he got rid of troublesome artifacts and
added an adjustable tripod to stabilize
the scope since magnification also
amplified the wobble of the user's hands
and so one thing that galileo did is he
actually reduced or stopped down the
aperture of the telescope you can see
one
behind me back there telescopes nowadays
you don't use the full
width of the of the objective lens you
use a reduced portion of it
and that's an innovation that galileo
perfected to get rid of what are called
optical aberrations
so it's kind of um counter-intuitive
paradoxical
you reduce the size effective size but
you magnify
in some sense the good qualities of the
lens that you've built
it was very difficult to get these
lenses and only one survives
and there's a there's a picture of it in
my book
which shows the the only remaining lens
of this type of galileo's
uh in that's still in existence that
galileo actually used
so it was a serious scientific invention
and that was used for scientific
purposes
so i i make a joke that galileo trusted
basically no one in that he
uh in a version of the current tv show
called shark tank he
went out and pitched this device to
investors
especially the venetian doge so in a
renaissance version of the television
show shark tank
he demonstrated the telescope that he
had perfected to prospective patrons
eventually he pitched it to the venetian
doge and senate they bought it several
copies in fact
they granted him a lifelong lectureship
in padua they also doubled his salary
as a professor i'm awestruck by galileo
not only did he instantly secure tenure
but his department chair also doubled
his startup funding
but it was the shortest tenured track
was not the thing that we envy most
it's that he was the first person to use
this device
to unlock telescopic vision for the very
first time
the culmination of galileo's discoveries
in siderius nuncius
really revolves around these
observations i'm showing a picture
uh from my book on
page uh 33 where i show the sketches
galileo made of the jew
of the jovian satellite system he had
correctly identified
that on succeeding knights there was a
pair of stars and eventually four stars
he called the medicine stars
after his uh funding source the medici
family
uh kasimo medici in particular and he
sketched out that
uh what he was seeing night after night
and eventually was led
by making vast tables to see the
periodicity
of these tiny points of light around the
giant orb jupiter which he could see
for the first time in human history with
his telescope
he was noting that they varied around it
in
periodic fashion and they did so with uh
with what he concluded must be the
effect of
a small miniature solar system which was
centered on jupiter not on the sun not
on the earth
and for the first time this overthrew
the dominant paradigm that the earth
is the center of the entire universe
in fact it showed not that the earth was
going around the sun
but it did make clear that there were
other points in our solar system that
could rightfully claim
their place as central to the orbit of
objects satellites around them
in this case we now know them as the
galilean moons not the medici stars
but galileo correctly summarized
surmised rather
that we were seeing a tiny solar system
on edge that if you look from above
you'd see
these four moons orbiting around jupiter
whereas we have one moon
jupiter has actually known now over 60
moons
and other planets have more than one
moon too in fact earth is the only
planet that has a moon
but only one moon uh other planets like
venus and mercury have no moons
and then all the other outer planets
have more than one moon including
mars which has two moons and so earth is
sort of unique in that way
it's also unique in that the moon of the
earth is exactly the same apparent
diameter
as the sun as viewed from the surface of
the planet there's no reason for that
it's just a happy coincidence that
allows us to have beautiful total solar
eclipses
uh some of which i've witnessed in my
life to now so far
and i hope to witness another one at
least from america in the year 2024
uh from somewhere in the midwest most
likely i hope you'll join me and
stay tuned for more information about
that but the moon figures uh mightily so
in uh in the siderius nuncius
but unfortunately for galileo it
features much less centrally
in the dialogue the dialogue and instead
the cause for much of the commotion
in this book revolves in the dialogue
revolves around galileo's insistence
that the earth is is going around
orbiting around the sun as the jovian
moons orbit around jupiter
and uh that the sun is instead roughly
stationary or is the central point about
which the earth
rotates now remember when galilei was
doing all of this we didn't even have
clocks
there was no such thing as a timepiece
no apple watches right
and so because of that it was very
difficult to keep accurate time measure
and it was very difficult to
to show things were completely uniform
and periodic
but it was a great puzzle to make use of
things that could tell time
because most of the observations galileo
makes in this book
have to do with in the dialogue i'm
speaking of now have to do with the
dynamics of things as they change as
they progress in time
we'll encounter balls rolling down
inclined planes that's
the bane of the existence of most uh uh
college uh you know students when they
first take physics and that usually
leads them to
take physics uh that branch of physics
called mechanics
the last class in physics they take
which i think is a great shame and i'll
talk about my philosophy of how we
should
actually go deeper and teach the deeper
matter
that surrounded the galilean discoveries
in the dialogue
and later in his next book his final
book called the discoursee
the discourse on two chief sciences
we'll talk about that maybe at the very
end and maybe someday we'll read that
together but for this book scope book
book collider whatever we're going to
call it um i want to
begin and there'll be a couple of
reading inside first of all this is very
inexpensive you can get this paperback
edition i'll give you a link
an affiliate link on amazon for which
i'll be grateful to accept a couple of
pennies
for everyone that buys it uh just full
disclosure
but it's really worth it this copy is
incredibly marked up
and i want to begin the discussion
by giving uh two other resources so
first one will be
obviously my book losing the nobel prize
has a lot of great information about
galileo
what it's like to be an observational
astronomer and how you use these
telescopic tools
and how we often felt fall victim to the
desire to confirm our particular
hypotheses that we're
investing so much of our life into an
understanding
and that's a phenomenon called
confirmation bias and it's something
that i personally have been
subjected to some of my best friends
have been subjected to it
it happens whether you're a theoretical
physicist a cosmologist an
experimentalist
what have you and no one is immune from
it and so it's something we constantly
have to be on guard of
uh the other aspect of the other free
resource is going to be
uh there'll be a wikipedia page i'll
point to
which is a great you know kind of
structure is going to give me the
summary kind of outline of the
points that i want to highlight it gives
the background details the different
the different main characters in the
real world and
that were subjecting galileo to the
ultimate fate in which he was
uh subjected to so i will give you that
information
in uh in the show notes in the links
below on youtube or in the show notes on
apple
podcast or wherever you get your podcast
i'll even
put a link to it on my webpage
briankeating.com
that you can make use of and we'll
illustrate it with some really
spectacular diagrams from the maestro as
he was referred to
galileo galilei so again unfortunately
you cannot download a audiobook version
of this i love audio books
i would love to make an audio book so
again please reach out to me if you're
interested in it
so uh if you want to follow along you
can first go to the wikipedia page
uh and it's called the title of pages
dialogue concerning the two chief world
systems
and it's a it's a great capsule summary
so we'll just go through that first
and then i'll go through each of the uh
chapters there's really only uh four
main chapters in the entire book
and before we even get to that i want to
read selections from
the introduction from albert einstein
and some of the commentary
by the translator stillman drake who is
just a heroic
scholar of galileo it turns out he did
such tremendous work
um on helping humanity understand
what galileo really meant in a book
that's almost 400 years old
to have the best translation come you
know 350 years after his death
is is pretty amazing uh and it really is
a testament to stillman drake and
one of the nice things about the drake
edition which is why i suggest you get
it
go out click the link buy it is that
he's got all sorts of little
um gutter notes or you know margin notes
that
uh we'll go over some of the ones that
are more prominent stick out in my mind
as really um encapsulating what is so
interesting and important
about this book and it serves as a
highlight extensively footnoted
at the back of the book with some
commentary from stillman drake himself
but he was such a genius uh this drake
and he has so many other good books that
you can get
uh including the cedirius nuncius
nuncious
some people will correct me i'm sure um
but
i i really hope that you'll take
advantage of it and get a copy of this
book
so i want to go over the wikipedia which
is of course free
and uh and put a uh and put
context the structure of the book how it
was uh
how it was uh prepared and i think
wikipedia does a good job of this so
this page dialogue concerning the two
cheap world systems you'll see this
picture at the top we'll talk about that
picture it's very important
and the picture uh sorry the the page
starts off the dialogue concerning the
two chief world systems
dialogue
is a 1632 italian language book
all of this is incredibly important the
dialogue the name
that we call it's called the dialogue
it's a little bit longer in italian but
first of all note it's written in
italian that becomes very important as
we'll explain
because galileo was actually forbidden
to teach copernicanism
teaching meaning speaking in terms that
an ordinary student could understand
which was speaking in italian not latin
his first book sidirius nuncius is latin
for starry messenger
and that was okay but in the 1616 uh
period he was forbidden to teach it
which meant to write in a language other
people could understand and promulgate
copernicanism
he ignored that maybe forgot about it
some say he might have even been framed
and actually that he never received such
an injunction
but it's very very curious to learn more
about it and to understand what galileo
might have been thinking
so right off the bat the title of the
book
dialogue that's in in italian
not in um not in latin which would have
been permissible
and the second part is that that was not
galileo's original title for this book
he actually originally intended to title
the book
with what he thought was the most
convincing evidence for the copernican
system
his original title was that smash
sounding
title that would obviously be a must
read
and that was on the flux and reflux of
the earth's tides
of the oceans uh and he wanted to do
that because he thought that
evidence that we'll get to in the fourth
day of this great dialogue
it takes place over four days in the
venice
mansion in venice is where the setting
is it's uh
really delightful to think about these
three characters over four days and they
talk about
going out for some brews or whatever
they're going to drink
and it's really cute the way galileo
structures it but again
the title originally would not have
caused any sensation
uh to our ears right now because on the
flux and reflux of the tides i don't
know how many people
would pick that book up uh also because
that argument is the least convincing
in fact it's probably the worst argument
for the earth's motion as we'll describe
so the pope and the index the pro the
inquisition really did galileo a favor
by at least for posterity's sake by
titling
forcing him to title the book as they
did
so this book is an italian language book
by galia galle comparing
the copernican system with the
traditional ptolemaic system
it was translated into latin as systema
cosmicom
in english the cosmic system in 1635 so
just three years after publication galio
didn't pass away
until 1642
and uh and so he lived quite a long time
under as we'll find out later house
arrest
uh the the book was dedicated to
galileo's patron ferdinando
uh the medici the grand duke of tuscany
who received the first printed copy on
february 22nd
1632 in the copernican system that
galileo is going to advocate for the
earth and other planets orbit the sun
while in the ptolemaic system everything
in the universe circles around the earth
the dialogue was published in florence
under a formal license from the
inquisition they permitted him to do it
but in 1633 galileo was found to be
vehemently suspect
of heresy that's kind of unusual based
on this book based on dialogue
uh which was then placed on the index of
forbidden books
from which it was not removed until
1835.
so 200 years after his trial and
after the book after the theories that
discussed have been permitted in print
in 1822 so again almost 180 years after
publication
in an action that was not announced at
the time the publication of anything
else he had written
or ever might write was also banned in
catholic countries
so it's of course incredibly fascinating
what happened
outside of this book and and i think it
bears
kind of repeating that this book is kind
of
come to be to personify if you will
the epic battle between science and
religion or god and science
setting them up as diametrically opposed
whereas galileo would think nothing of
the sort
he was a pragmatist in some ways he was
sort of naive in other ways politically
speaking of course so over the next you
know a couple of hours we're going to
get into
the structure of the book the different
days in the book the translation
notes by stillman drake the forward by
albert einstein
uh and so i hope you'll stay tuned i
hope you'll uh subscribe and like and
comment
let me know what you want to hear in
particular about this wonderful book
and i look forward to getting your
feedback and hopefully this will be the
first of many adventures
or maybe it'll be the last so for now
uh signing off and look forward to an
illustrated annotated
keating's eye view of the greatest one
of the greatest books
in scientific history galileo's dialogue
concerning the two chief world systems
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]